so I think we're at a time where
everyone's really waking up to the way
that we abuse our power and treat those
with less power devastated and enraged
Whitney Cummings is speaking out about
the allegations against Chris D'Elia in
a Twitter post on Sunday the actress who
worked with Chris on her NBC show
Whitney wrote it's taken me a couple
days to process the information I have
learned about Chris I'm devastated and
enraged by what I've read and learned
Whitney added this is a pattern of
predatory behavior this abuse of power
is enabled by silence now that I'm aware
I won't be silent Chris was recently
accused by multiple women of sexual
harassment and grooming the comedian who
recently starred on the second season of
Netflix is you that's not gonna save you
okay nothing Ken he's trying to get in
my head was first accused of misconduct
by Twitter user Simone Rossi
Simone tweeted I still can't believe
Netflix cast Chris D'Elia as a pedophile
in season two of you like the literal
irony she then shared screenshots of
alleged emails between her and Chris
from when she was 16 the emails appeared
to show the comedian asking Simone to
meet up after his live shows and
requesting photos from her for the
longest time I thought it was
embarrassing for me that I was
interacting with this older man but he
was the one who deemed me on Twitter and
was the one who was twice my age and was
the one that used the power imbalance
between us to his advantage so Chris
D'Elia
Simone added I am also definitely not
the only underage girl he did this to
you just an FYI another twitter user
responded to Simone's story with
allegations of her own she wrote he
solicited nudes off of me when I was 17
years old and constantly messaged me
whenever he was touring Vancouver and
asked me to come backstage to his shows
I am so unsurprised that multiple girls
are coming out with almost the exact
story as mine it's a known fact he's a
[ __ ] perv and he plays those roles
perfectly when acting
in a statement to ET Chris denied any
illegal or non-consensual activity and
apologized forgetting quote caught up in
my lifestyle
Whitney continued by writing girls
should be able to be a fan of a comedian
they admire without becoming a sexual
target it's the adults responsibility to
be an adult all of these sort of
stereotypical qualities that women have
not as weaknesses but as strengths being
sensitive being emotional I feel like we
get shamed for that another comedian
speaking out Amy Schumer while she
didn't directly name Chris in her post
Amy praise the brave women coming
forward on Twitter she wrote there are
great men out there and there are men
who humiliate and abuse women and girls
because of a power dynamic or because
when they were that age girls wouldn't
talk to them whatever your reasoning is
or was we are watching you and we are
all together now and we won't accept
this behavior whether you break the law
or not
[Music]